ich bin offiziell der dümmste Mensch der
Welt aber jetzt mal von Anfang an und
willkommen zu einem neuen ramadanblock
haben sie gibt mir einfach diese
45-Jährigen Familienvater Vibes wie ihr
so Angelegenheit klärt die habe ich mir
vorgenommen dass ich mir safe and
Macaron gönnen werde zum Iftar und wie
schön sind bitte diese Geschenkkarten
wer würde sich nicht darüber freuen
außerdem haben wir noch passendes
Geschenkpapier hier wollte ich euch
einmal unsere Arbeitsteilung zeigen wir
haben so ein oversized T-Shirt darüber
kommt dann diese Kaki farbene Schürze
die geht hinten über Kreuz und ich finde
die Mega stylisch okay wirklich ein
bisschen lost aber ja morgen Besuch
kriegen habe ich hier schon mal meine
berühmten Zigarette eingeräumt so gut
vorbereiten und dann kam mir der
Geistesblitz im Backofen waren einfach
meine Ofenkartoffeln Leute ich hatte so
Bock auf die gestern ich habe sie
einfach nicht gegessen weil sie
vergessen habe für mich da nehme ich mir
meine Schilddrüse Tablette ich bin von
25 runtergekommen danke Schwarzkümmelöl
ich habe alleine gegessen also gab es
etwas mit Champignons weil ich ja eben
alleine bin und haben sie keine
Champignons mag und das war's auch schon
bis morgen